Okay.
When we think about the United Nations,
then we think about exactly that, an
organization, a political organization
bringing the nations together.
And that sounds like uh something
commendable.
And the question is, is that all that
there is behind it? Do you remember that
at the Tower of Babel, God separated the
nations? Now, if you look at the
headquarters of the United Nations in
New York, this is really quite a
fascinating building. It is large.
And the name United Nations was coined
by United States President Franklin D.
Rousfelt
and was used in the declaration by
United Nations of January 1942
during the Second World War when
representatives of 26 nations pledged
their governments to continue fighting
together against what they called the
Axis powers.
Interesting name, Axis Powers. Today
there's another axis that is being
fought and that is known as the axis of
evil. Have you heard of that?
The forerunner of the United Nations was
the League of Nations and this was an
organization in similar circumstances
during the first world war and
established in 1919
under the treaty of Versailles to
promote the international cooperation
and to achieve peace and security. This
comes straight from the UN web page. So
nothing strange about that. It's just
plain history.
Some more from that. In 1945,
representatives of 50 countries met in
San Francisco at the United Nations
Conference on International
Organizations and they drew up a United
Nations charter
and those delegates deliberated on the
basis of proposals worked out by
representatives of China, Soviet Union,
United Kingdom, United States at
Dumbartan Oaks, United States in August
October 1944. It was signed on 26th June
1945.
50 countries. Poland was not represented
and became one of the original 51 member
states. So it officially came into
existence on the 24th of October 1945
when the charter was ratified by China,
France, Soviet Union, United Kingdom,
United States and by a majority of the
other signaries
and every
24th of October they celebrate this
founding of the United Nations.
Now let's have a look at this charter of
the United Nations. This is a very
interesting piece of history. Well,
Arthur Balffor, do you remember that
name? We've used it before. Who was a
member of Hort's Apostles. You remember
Hort? This was the professor that uh
helped to produce the Greek text that
changed the emphasis of the Bible and
removed many of the aspects of Jesus
Christ's power and sovereignty from the
word of God. And the apostles were the
secret society
that uh functioned and at that time and
Hort was a member as well as Arthur
Balfur. Hort called this group a senior
apostles club as well as president of
the psychic research society society for
psychic research soon became prime
minister of England Arthur Balffor and
instrumental in the first league of
nations. So this president, this prime
minister was also of course active in
the writing of the original charter of
the League of Nations much of which
formed the basis for the United Nations.
He not only headed the society for
psychic research holding seances at his
home but he initiated a group called the
synthetic society whose goal was to
create a one world religion. That's a
very interesting point of history. And
he invited a certain Frederick Mayers of
the Society of Psychic Research to join.
And together they created the preamble
of all religions. And it includes the
dogma departed spirits can communicate.
Obviously, if you belong to such an
society,
then that is part of the situation. So
built in somewhere over there was the
wish to bring all religions together.
Now let's have a look at some of the
historic figures of the United Nations.
Algahis, he became the acting secretary
general of the establishment of the
United Nations. The April 16, 1945 issue
of Time magazine called him one of the
State Department's brighter young men.
It was his and Joseph E. Johnson who
later became secretary of the
Bilderberggers. So here we have all the
secret societies again who wrote much of
the United Nations charter. So very high
Freemasons Bilderberers were responsible
for this charter. Now we know what they
believe. We've already had a lecture on
that and I would refer people back to
that lecture patenting it after the
constitution of Russia and the communist
manifesto. This is very interesting. So
the constitution of the USSR is almost
identical to the constitution of the
United Nations for those who did not
know that. And there are all the
references. Everything that I say is
referenced. I'm just reading. So please
nobody get angry with me. Get angry if
you want to with whoever set this thing
up. I had nothing to do with it.
Remember that I also pointed out in
previous lectures who the responsible
persons were for trying to bring all the
nations together in a unitary government
and then behind the scenes another
organizations to bring all the religions
together. But this was not the primary
or public domain. This was more the
secret domain. Winston Churchill. He was
the one who was also responsible of
course after the war in setting up this
whole organization. The creation of an
authorative world order is the ultimate
aim to which we must strive and the
United Nations formed part of that.
Charles de Gaul who was also
instrumental. Nations must unite in a
world government or perish.
So the big figures involved had this
philosophy.
Then there is a man, I don't know how to
pronounce his name, Triger Lee. The
first official UN Secretary General, was
a high-ranking member of Norway's Social
Democratic Party, which was, by the way,
an offshoot of the third communist
international. And then came a man, Doug
Hamuscott,
and he was the second secretary general.
He was a Swedish socialist. He openly
pushed communist policy. And then came
Utant the third secretary general and he
was a Marxist. So here you can see how
the philosophy in the beginning was
programmed. Now I would like you to
understand that this is not a method to
go anti- capitalist because the United
States was a signary of this charter. So
why would the United States actually
sign something that was so obviously
contrary to their own philosophy? Well,
if you remember the Hegelian principle
where two opposing viewpoints are set
into the world and neither of them is
really the viewpoint you want to
achieve, what you really want to achieve
is a synthesis between the two.
So what you see actually is you see
socialists
in the overriding capacity of secretary
generals. Although whether they have
Marxist leanings or capitalist leanings
at that level doesn't make any
difference. The method is just to bring
about a synthesis which is the desired
government of all of them. So out of
this chaos you eventually get whatever
you want. Now Utant he was of course one
of the earliest secretary generals. He
said, "World Federalists hold before us
the vision of a united man unified
mankind living in peace under a just
world order. The heart of the program, a
world under law is realistic and
attainable." Just to remind you of what
we have said before. And of course
behind the scenes always you have the
papacy. As you can see in all of these
lectures, the papacy always very heavily
involved. Here is Pope Paul V 6th with
Secretary General Utant. Now, this man
was a Marxist or let's rather put it
this way, publicly he pushed a Marxist
agenda.
But if he was a true insider, then he
had neither agenda. And this was just
for an appearance sake as Hegel also
said. So it is not surprising that here
we have a handshake with another
secretary gent general whose name was
Valtime.
Now what was the agenda or what was the
political view of Valty? Anybody know?
Anybody want to venture a guess?
became public knowledge and there was a
hu and huge outcry as a result. He was a
Nazi.
Yes. So you can see that heelian
philosophy coming out here. There you
have Marxism,
anti-thesis, there you have um
Nazism, thesis in between
synthesis. So it didn't really matter
which of the philosophies they inspe
Paul V 6 by the way is the first one to
introduce this bent cross or broken
cross. Let's read about uh what this
means. Pope Paul V 6 wrote a papal
encyclical that called on the nations to
abandon sovereignty to form a world
government. So the pope himself was
behind this and actually called for such
a government. And about this twisted
cross, here's the quote for you. Paul V
6th made use of a sinister symbol used
by Satanists in the sixth century that
had been revived at the time of Vatican
2. This was a bent or broken cross on
which was displayed a repulsive and
distorted figure of Christ which the
black magicians and sorcerers of the
Middle Ages had made use of to represent
the biblical term mark of the beast.
Interesting quote. Yet not only Paul V
6, but his successor,
the two John Paul's carried that object
and held it up to be revered by the
crowds who had not the slightest idea
that it stood for Antichrist.
So that's a quote that's very
interesting about the broken cross and
what it stands for. So these are the
figures behind or the movers of the
United Nations. a pope calling for such
an order. The secretary generals picking
it up, reiterating it on both sides of
the political divide so that uh it would
seem fair to both sides of the
philosophy. Now what about the spiritual
aspect?
There's one interfaith organization that
is called the temple of understanding
and uh it has a newsletter which is
called world goodwill newsletter. Now we
have to see what authority such an
organization has because there are many
little organizations and they could just
be you know irritating little piddly
little organizations. So who are these
people who formed the temple of
understanding with a newsletter, the
world goodwill newsletter, an
organization affiliated to the United
Nations. It's always good to look at the
founders.
Well, founded by Juliet Hollister in
1960, the Temple of Understanding has
one of its goals, the creation of a
spiritual United Nations in its work to
promote understanding between religions
on the basis of the oneness of the human
family. Sounds good. The temple has
numbered among its members and
supporters such influential world
service as a Utant himself. Well,
there's the secretary general. You can't
go much higher than that. Elellanena
Roosefeld that's interesting Thomas
Mertton Yavalu Anva Sadat Radak Krishnan
in addition to the main center of New
York. So these are the top movers. So
this is not some sort of uh little
organization operating somewhere in the
wings. This is a hub organization.
And from where did they operate? Well,
they were based at the Cathedral of St.
John the Divine. They must be getting
pretty boring by now, right? Always the
same thing. The temple has active
chapters in India, in the UK,
representatives in Africa, Latin
America, Asia, Middle East. This is a
universal movement to bring all
religions together. Let's have a look at
this interesting cathedral. There it is,
the Cathedral of St. John the Divine.
The cathedral is located at the 112th
Street in Amsterdam Avenue, one block
east of Broadway, the largest cathedral
in the world. That's also interesting.
The cathedral uh church of St. John the
Divine in in New York is the mother
church of the Episcopal Dascese of New
York and the seat of its bishop.
remember that's where they had the
female Christ and where they have the
issue of uh ordaining homosexual bishops
and all kinds of interesting stuff
happened at this episcosip
right
Jim Garrison president of the new age
Gorbachof Foundation which was this
foundation that was founded by Gorbachof
in New York he said we are going to end
up with the world government. It's
inevitable. There's going to be
conflict, coercion, and consensus.
That's all part of what will be required
as we give birth to the first global
civilization. So that's the agenda that
they have. Philip Jessup, a CFR member,
world court justice, pretty high up
people, writes, I agree that national
sovereignty is the root of all evil. So
nations will obviously have to
relinquish their sovereignty to this
organization without it appearing as if
they are doing so. The humanist
manifesto two states we deplore the
division of mankind on nationalistic
grounds. We have reached a turning point
in human history where the best option
to transcend the limits of national
sovereignty and to be move towards
building a world community. That's human
manifesto one and two. These are the
official documents. Now, this is a very
interesting man, Robert Miller. He's the
former assistant secretary general to
the United Nations, but uh he is today
the mover in the spiritual field within
the United Nations. He's also called the
prophet of hope of the United Nations.
He wrote, "We must move as quickly as
possible to a one world government, a
one world religion under a one world
leader." That's very, very interesting.
So, these are the top movers. Now, the
philosophy, I I'm always interested in
what the philosophy is and who's behind
it. And again, we pick up the same old
names over and over and over again. In
the Aquarian Conspiracy by Marilyn
Fergusy, Ferguson, a survey of new
aagers showed that the leading influence
on their spiritual awakening was again
Pierre Talhart de Charardin. Do you
remember who he was?
Jesuit
priest. You see, there you have
Catholicism, the Jesuits, the top movers
in the United Nations. Now, what did
Robert Mueller, the former assistant
secretary general, have to say? He wrote
Tailhad Desadin had always viewed the
United Nations as the progressive
institutional
embodiment of his philosophy. Now there
is a secretary general saying or under
secretary general saying that the United
Nations embodies the philosophy of
Tylard de Chardin.
Now what did Tyhart say? I've mentioned
some of his philosophy. We'll look in a
little bit more detail again. Tylard
wrote, "Although the form is not necess
not yet discernible, mankind tomorrow
will awaken to a pan organized world."
Panorganized world. Well, okay. What
else do you have to say?
Tyler Dashadin influenced his companion
father de Bre who inspired colleagues
who started rich process of global and
long-term thinking in the United Nations
which affected many nations and people
around the world. Robert Muller says I
have myself been deeply influenced by
Thailand. So the under secretary general
of the United Nations who's today
entrusted with the spiritual aspects of
the United Nations plus its education
program says he's influenced by Taihart
desardin
and Robert Miller writes most of all
they taught me happiness his work he
says any Tardian will recognize in this
the spiritual transcendence which he
announced so emphatically as the next
step in our evolution.
So there's going to be a spiritual
transcendence from what appears to be
political over to the spiritual.
All right. We've already seen in a
previous lecture that he was a French
Jesuit priest, a eugenist, a Marxist, a
pantheist, evolutionist.
He might have even been involved in the
Piltown hoax. He was a humanist and a
proponent of a one world government. And
he's the father of the new age. So he's
a very prominent man. seems to have been
very busy. He dreamed of humanity
merging into God and each realizing his
own godhood at the Omega point. This
belief has inspired many of the new age
leaders. In fact, Charardine is one of
the most frequently quoted writers by
leading new age occultists that we've
had too when we discussed the new age
movement. But just to remind you, so we
can merge into God. This is what the man
looks like. This comes straight from the
Jesuit web pages themselves. And uh
they'll talk about his evolutionary
synthesis,
world of the mind and spirit, physical
world with the world of mind and spirit,
the union of those. And uh here are a
few of his quotes just to go into a
little bit of detail. This is the spirit
of the philosophy of the United Nations.
Interesting. It is a law of the universe
that in all things there is prior
existence. Before every form there is a
prior but lesser evolved form. Each one
of us is evolving towards Godhead.
So we are all becoming
God. Wonderful philosophy. What I am
proposing to do is to narrow that gap
between pantheism and Christianity
by bringing out what one might call the
Christian soul of pantheism or the
pantheist aspect of Christianity.
That's fascinating. So God is in
everything. God is not a separate
entity. We ourselves are God or part of
God. If you are a pantheist, that's what
you believe.
I can be saved only by come becoming one
with the universe. That's pantheism.
It's also the philosophy of Buddhism.
I believe the Messiah whom we await whom
we all without any doubt await is the
universal Christ. That is to say the
Christ of evolution.
Right? That's Tyler Shadin's philosophy.
Isn't that interesting? So unfortunately
I cannot agree with one single iota of
that philosophy. It's not biblical. In
fact it's blasphemous.
A general convergence of religions upon
a universal Christ who satisfied them
all. That's what Tylard desin said.
Christianity and evolution. This is his
quote. His quote. So a conversion of
religion that satisfies them all. And he
saw the United Nations as the embodiment
of this philosophy. That seems to me the
only possible conversion of the world
and the only form in which a religion of
the future can be conceived.
That means everybody must come together.
Now how do you get all the religions to
come together and to bury the hatchets
and their differences?
You create a pain of separation,
chaos that exceeds the pain of unity.
Is that understandable? That's how you
do it. That's healian philosophy. That
is Freemason philosophy. So today we're
in the pain stage and the next phase
will be unity or un inexplicable pain.
That's the choice. And mankind will
quite readily choose which one
the lesser pain obviously to survive.
Now let's have a look at all these
secretary generals and whether they are
actually embodying this philosophy or
not. This is Doug Halma Agnikal
Hamashkot. He was the secretary general
of the United Nations from 10 April 1953
to 1961.
Then he met his death in a plane crash
and um he was the fourth son of the
prime minister of Sweden during the
years of World War I. He was the first
one. Now what did he do in the United
Nations? Well, one of the first things
he did was to produce or create a prayer
room. And there it is on the left hand
side. uh a stone in the middle of the
room was placed to tell us we may see it
as an altar empty not because there is
no god not because it is an altar to an
unknown god but because it is dedicated
to the god whom man worships under many
names and many forms.
Very interesting. So there is this
prayer room with only this stone altar
which is built to be shaped like a like
a
rectangle if you like which has certain
interesting meanings and the whole
building the whole room has the shape of
a trapezoid.
Now what does that mean? Well, there's
also an allseeing eye. And that symbol
that we see over here in amongst the
Hittites is also the symbol, if you look
carefully, of the United Nations, which
has the laurel wreath and which has the
face up there, which is just replaced
with the earth. Now, perhaps the best
way to comprehend what the allseeing eye
represents is to examine the
architecture of the meditation room of
the United Nations building in New York.
The meditation room is shaped as a
pyramid, a trapezoid without the
capstone. Inside the room is dimly lit,
but coming from the ceiling is a narrow
but concentrated pinpoint beam of light
which radiates down to a bleak stone
altar.
On the walls straight ahead is a
breathtaking modernistic mural that is
dynamically endowed with occult
symbolism containing 27 triangles and
various configurations, a mixture of
black and white and colored background
and a snake- like vertical line. At the
center is the allseeing eye which grips
the millions of annual UN visitors with
its stark beckoning image of suspicion
and omniresence. This is the quote from
Tex Mars and some more quotes. The
meditation room faces northn northeast.
To enter the room, one must proceed from
darkness into light.
Indeed, the middle order of the satanic
brotherhood is called the order of the
trapezoid. That's very interesting. And
Anton Levy who was the founder of the
church of Satan refers to an occult
principle known as the law of the
trapezoid. So we seem to have a very
occult room here which is dedicated to a
god that can be served under any name. H
the one that I know has one name.
One name.
One could tell several moving stories
writes Robert Miller the spiritual
godfather if you like of the United
Nations and the former uh under
secretary general. One could tell
several moving stories of the spiritual
transformation of the United Nations has
caused to the point that this little
speck on earth is becoming holy ground.
For example, the rational intellectual
economist Doug Hamuscol found God at the
United Nations and inspiration for his
work as a world servant in the mystics
of the Middle Ages. Oh, so he didn't
find it from the Bible. He found it
where? from the mystics
towards the end of his markings overflow
with spirituality and mysticism. There
are the words of the United Nations
themselves or their representatives
telling us how this inspiration came
about.
Now let's go back a little bit to Foster
and Alice Bailey.
These were Alice A. Bailey, the one who
received dictated messages from Dwal
Koul and who is known as the prophetess
of the new age. They started a group
called World Goodwill, an official
non-governmental
organization within the United Nations.
The stated aim of this group is to
cooperate in the world of preparation
for the reappearance of the Christ. So
the United Nations in other words is an
organization preparing to get all the
religion all the governments together.
Yes. But that is just on a political
level. The agenda behind it is to bring
all the religions together and to
prepare it for the coming of Christ.
Which Christ?
not Jesus Christ but the cosmic Christ
because Jesus Christ is not coming as we
will see in a future lecture to do what
they think it's going to happen their
Christ wants to have a kingdom here on
earth but God says my kingdom is not of
this earth
now let's have a look at this man Robert
Miller there he is Dr. Robert Miller,
former assistant secretary general of
the United Nations, Chancellor of the
United Nations University of Peace, and
he's chairperson of the Peace Party
2000. He's a very prominent man. What
does he write? Robert Miller. Decide to
open yourself to God, to the universe,
to all your brethren and sisters, to
your inner self, to the potential of the
human race, to the infinity of your
inner self, and you will become the
universe. You will become infinity and
you will at long last
your you will be at long last your real
divine stupendous self.
There you have the same philosophy. So
what is he saying that we can become
gods? All right. So that is the mover
and the shaker of the philosophy of the
United Nations.
Robert Miller writes in world core
curriculum the following. Now this is
stunning.
The underlying philosophy
upon which the Robert Miller school now
what is the Robert Miller school? We'll
have to come to that. Robert Miller
school is the education program for the
entire world as will be enforced by the
United Nations. That's scary.
Let's read on. The underlying philosophy
upon which the Robert Miller school is
based will be found in the teachings set
forth in the books of Alice A. Bailey.
Hello. The books of Alice A. Bailey were
published originally by Lucifer
Publishing Company which because of all
the flack they changed to Lucus Trust.
Isn't that correct?
The school is now certified as a United
Nations Associated School providing
education for international cooperation
and peace. Okay, this is big business.
So the philosophy is based on Luciferian
chneled writings preparing for the
coming of Lucifer. And remember what
they said, they were quite open about
it. Alice Bailey claimed evidence of the
growth of human intellect along the
needed receptive lines for the
preparation of the new age can be seen
in the planning of various nations and
in the efforts of the United Nations to
formulate a world plan. From the very
start of this infoldment, three occult
factors have governed the development of
all these plans. Now, can you see why I
called the lecture the UN and the occult
agenda? Because Alice Bailey says there
were three occult plans and Robert
Miller says yes we follow the writings
of Alice Bailey. She did not spell them
out but she did state within the United
Nations is a germ and seed of a great
international
and meditating reflective group. A group
of thinking and informed men and women
in whose hands lies the destiny of
humanity. Ooh, this is largely under the
control of many forthray disciples if
you could but realize it. And their
point of meditative focus is the
intuitional or Buddha plane. The plane
upon which all hierarchical activity is
today to be found. That's about as
occult as you can get. What she is
saying is that the inner core of the
United Nations is controlled by people
who are under the control of Lucifer.
That's what she's saying. She's saying
it's demonic and it's out of her words,
not mine. I'm just reading. That's
what's such fun about all of this.
Helena Petrovnllki, founder of
Theosophy. She was the forerunner of
course of the Bailey books and theosophy
was then taken over by Annie Ward Basant
over here and then taken over by Alice
A. Bailey and here is the great
invocation that has to be read and
learned by every child in the future.
From the point of light within the mind
of God, let light stream forth into the
minds of men. Let light descend on
earth. From the point of love within the
heart of God, let love stream forth into
the hearts of men. May Christ return to
earth. But this Christ is not Jesus
Christ.
From the center where the will of God is
known, let purpose guide the little
wills of men. Oh, how neat. It's so
derogatory. The purpose which the
masters know and serve. What arrogance.
From the center which we call the race
of men, let the plan of love and light
work out, and may it seal the door where
evil dwells.
This is interesting. Which door is to be
sealed where evil dwells? Well, if you
know occult science, you'll know that
they call light darkness and darkness
light. And they say that Jesus is the
evil one. We read all those quotes when
we did the the lecture on that issue.
May sealed it all where evil dwells. Let
light and love and power restore the
plan on earth.
Restore what plan?
Restore whose plan and who made it so
that it is not restored? Well, who
separated the nations?
God separated the nations. What is the
focus of the United Nations to unite the
nations? So they want to restore that
which the inadverted commas evil one
happened to mess up with one brilliant
move of confusing the languages.
Well just goes to show one word of God
and he's confused for four and a half
thousand years. Who's really in control
here?
Well, here's Annie Basant in her 33
degree Freemason regalia co-masonry. You
remember we dealt with this issue. The
theosophy textbook teaches immortality,
reincarnation, the deity of man.
Statements by this dwell who also
inspired Alice A. Bailey.
He says talks about Alice A. Bailey know
me still by another name and office. Aab
Alice A. Bailey knows who I am and
recognizes me by two of my names.
Now that's interesting because there are
two names and we will see the two names
in a future lecture what the names are
and then it gets very interesting. This
is a detective story. It's a very
exciting one.
Well, the Bible says that they are
spirits of demons
working miracles which go forth to the
kings of the earth and to the whole
world to gather them to the battle of
that great great day of God Almighty.
Revelation 16:14
remember that Helena Petrovnavlavski the
founder of this movement of which Alice
A Bailey became the high priestess if
you like said Lucifer represents life
thought progress civilization liberty
independence Lucifer is the logos the
serpent the savior it is Satan who is
the god of our planet and the only one
then she talks about the virgin who is
Satan and Lucifer er at the same time
and the Holy Ghost all wrapped in one.
So whether you call him Isis or whether
you call him Osiris doesn't matter
whether you call him Baal and Ashtaret
doesn't matter. Two names he always
comes under two names, two principles.
Alice A Bailey, she succeeded Basant as
leader of theosophy. Her husband was a
32deree Freemason and also of course
part of co-masonry. There she is.
Priestess and prophetess of the new age
movement who received these messages
from this
spirit entity which has to be a demon
dwell core. Her writings as we have said
one of two women to be one of the most
prolific writers of modern times. Her
main aim, the problems of humanity,
getting all humanity together again and
preparing the world for the coming of
Christ. And we have read this quote
already. I dedicate myself a new to the
service of the coming one. One is an
acrimon for Lucifer
and will do all I can to prepare men's
minds and hearts for that event. I have
no other life intention.
She writes, "The Tibetan, this is now
this dwell has asked me to make clear
that when he is speaking of the Christ,
he's referring to his official name as
head of the hierarchy.
The Christ works for all men
irrespective of their faith. He does not
belong to the Christian world anymore
than to the Buddh Buddhist or Muhammadan
or any other faith. There is no need for
any man to join the Christian church in
order to be affiliated with Christ." So
obviously it's not Christianity.
The requirements are to love your fellow
men, lead a disciplined life, recognize
the divinity in all faiths and all
beings, and rule your daily life with
love. Love, love, love, love, love until
it drips. That's the modern gospel.
You're never allowed to warn anyone.
You're never allowed to talk about sin.
You're never allowed to talk about
salvation. You're never allowed to point
to Jesus Christ as the only savior.
That's contrary to the law of love.
Isn't that sick? If you love someone,
don't you warn them of the hazards and
the problems ahead?
First of all, he will come to a world
which is essentially one world. Alice a
Bailey wrote. So it doesn't even have to
be a fully united world. The major
effect of his appearance will surely be
to demonstrate in every land the effect
of a spirit of inclusiveness. Now I want
you to ponder this. This is very
important.
So his main aim will be to develop a
spirit of inclusiveness.
An inclusiveness which will be channeled
or expressed through him. So his spirit
will work to bring this about. All who
seek right human relations will be
gathered automatically to him. Ah so not
all who seek Jesus Christ. No, all who
seek right human relations, can you see
the emphasis to mankind again? All who
seek these will automatically be
gathered to him whether they are in one
of the great world religions or not.
So we need a spirit of inclusiveness.
But let's continue. All who see no true
or basic difference between religion and
religion or between man and man or
nation and nation will rally around him.
Have you got that? So if there's if I
see no difference between Christianity
and Buddhism and I see no difference
between Hinduism and Christianity, I
will rally around him. If I see no
difference between the nations, I will
rally around him. Now those who embody
the spirit of exclusiveness
and separateness
will stand automatically and equally
revealed and all men will know them for
what they are.
Oh nice.
What does the Bible say on this issue?
The Bible says come out and be
separate.
The Bible asks for a spirit of
separateness.
The United Nations by its very nature
has no option but to ask for a spirit of
inclusiveness.
But now what if the high movers behind
the scenes are actually occultists and
Luciferians?
Wouldn't that be kind of scary? Because
who would be the head honcho of the team
then behind the scenes?
Satan. Satan would be the head honcho.
He would be the main guy. Now the
trouble is
this difference. Those who say come out
and be separate, they're going to be in
trouble. Those who say, "Well, let's be
inclusive," they'll be okay. The reply
comes with clarity. He will come
unfailingly when a measure of peace has
been restored. We don't have to have
world peace, just a measure of peace.
Alice Bailey continues, "The major
required preparation for the coming of
the Christ is a world at peace. However,
that peace must be based on an educated
goodwill which will lead inevitably to
right human relations and therefore to
the establishments of on lines of light
between nation and nation, religion and
religion, group and group, man and man.
So the only way we're going to have this
community is by putting everybody into
the melting pot and becoming one. That
means giving up your differences.
Discover the members of the new group of
world service whenever possible and
strengthen their hands. Look for them in
every nation and expressing expressing
many lines of thoughts and points of
view. Remember always that in doctrine
and dogma and in techniques and methods
they may differ widely from you. But in
love for their fellow man that has
become the religion of the new world.
Not love for God, love for the fellow
man. In practical goodwill and in
devotion to the establishment of right
human relations, they stand with you.
They are your equals and can probably
teach you much. So forget all about the
religious differences. promote
ceaselessly the work of world goodwill
so that every nation may have its own
group of men and women dedicated to the
establishment of right human
relationships.
The whole power has to shift to man
rather than to God. It is on the
foundation of this teaching that Christ
will raise the super structure of the
brotherhood of man for right human
relations on expression of the love of
God. And this is all we hear in the
sermonizing of the new world. What is
important is right human relations. What
is important is that we accept one
another as we are. What we and it goes
on and on and on and on.
But
faithfulness to God, biblical
principles, no, they have to be given
up.
Share International says, "But the day
will dawn when the vision of the United
Nations will save the world. And when
the reality of the United Nations starts
bearing fruit, then the breath of
immortality
will be a living reality on earth." And
there is the spiritual leader of the or
the present priest if you like in the
United Nations, the Hindu Sri Chimoi. He
says the United Nations is the way the
way to oneness that leads to the supreme
oneness capitalized. It is like a river
flowing towards the source the ultimate
source and the United Nations becomes
for us the answer to world suffering,
world darkness, world ignorance. The
inner vision of the United Nations is
the gift supreme and this will be
realized no matter how many years it
takes. The Dalai Lama says in the sphere
of international relations, the sense of
greater shared responsibility is
particularly needed. Today, when the
world is becoming increasingly
interdependent, the dangers of
irresponsible behavior have dramatically
increased. Unless we realize that we now
are part of one big human family, we
cannot hope to bring about peace and
happiness. So all the world leaders are
saying these things and the United
Nations with its symbolism
of this ancient laurel wreath around a
globe is nothing other than the
emulation of an old pagan ideal which
Lucifer once more wants to realize in
the world that we live in today.
as we have seen the symbol of the United
Nations
is very similar to the old Hittite
symbol where you had in the center the
face of the sun god and now you just
have a web if you like a spider's which
is a symbol of Lucifer and the
encompassing earth and of course the
laurel wreath was a symbol of all the
ancient deities. So we find all for one
all together now we are the world was
the 50th celebration of the United
Nations
the new age agenda was to merge God and
nature that's what Tyler Dashardin the
father of the philosophy of the UN said
we must become pantheistic eradicate
male female distinction world peace
nuclear disarmament one world government
one world religion The organizations
leading up to this, the United Nations
of course, Council of Foreign Relations,
Trilateral Commission, Bilderberers,
Gorbachov Foundation, and the Club of
Rome. And they've already put up a
constitution which is known as the
Constitution for the Federation of
Earth. So we really have a world
constitution.
Now, obviously, if you want to bring
about a situation like that, you have to
influence the education of the world. So
that the mindset and the thinking of
people is changed. So education is a
very important point. This comes
straight from their own web pages. Wow.
You cannot say this is hearsay. It comes
straight from them. Unol.org.
The world will not change and find peace
if there is not a new education. Utant
former secretary general of the United
Nations. We need a new education. The
old one's no good. The former director
of the World Health Organization Dr.
Brock Chisum, of course, that's also a
United Nations organization, says to
achieve world government, it is
necessary to remove from the minds of
men their individualism.
That's kind of scary, don't you think?
Loyalty to family traditions. Oh, that's
even worse. National patriotism and
religious dogmas. Now, these are the
movers of the United Nations. Your
individualism must go. You must become a
number. just doing what the state says.
This is Marxism. The state is supreme
and you are nothing but the catacuman, a
goyam or nothing. And you must give up
your individuality. Did you know that
Christ created us all free agents? Every
single one of us. No one to be subject
to anyone but God. Because only to God
can you trust your subjection because he
is 100% selflessness which he proved
when he came to this earth. How would
you like to be a subject of Lucifer and
be bound by chains to his chariots to do
his whims? I would hate that. But in any
case, in order to do that, you'll have
to give up your individualism.
Now let's have a look again at this man,
Robert Miller, philosopher, prophet of
hope, top level global statesman and uh
what a mighty man. He's the chancellor
of the University of peace created by
the United Nations. He uh is the creator
of what is known as the world core
curriculum that says everything and he's
known throughout as the world as the
father of global education. There are 29
Robert Miller schools around the world.
more being established each year. World
core curriculum earned him the UNESCO
Peace Prize in 1989. He has recently
drawn up a framework for world media
coverage. What you see on your
television is what you're supposed to
see, not what you should see
as a public service as well as a
framework for planetary and cosmic
consciousness. Wow. So, your mindset,
your cultural mindset must be changed.
your framework for the arts and culture.
These are our cultists speaking. After
all, he said so himself. He says he
follows Alice. Bailey is the author of
the World Core curriculum. What does
that do? Everything is a quote. Steer
our children towards global citizenship,
earth centered belief, socialist values,
the collective mindset which is becoming
a requirement of the 20th century
workforce. Your children will have to be
modified. We are living in a frightening
world.
Good. Robert Melo, what does he write
about a world core curriculum? He says,
"A world core curriculum might seem
utopian today,
but by the end of the year 2000, have we
passed that?"
Yes. It will be down to earth daily
reality in what does it say there? All
the schools of the world. Now believe
you me I have been in the education
system. I officially left the education
system one month ago and what I have
seen in the last few years the changes
are hair raising hair raising. If that
is what is awaiting us then God help
this world. We've already seen he says
the philosophy is based on Alice A
Bailey
and world core curriculum. This is
unol.org.
That is their own one. What is their
teaching? Our planetary home. Place in
the universe. Our place in time. That's
all the evolution stories. The family of
humanity. That's global humanity. The
miracle of individual life. And the
coordinating centers of the world where
they all are. The Robert Miller schools
international. What do they teach? Well,
they teach they have, for example, the
Shaman Institute and they have all these
nice interesting occult signs for all
the things that they stand for. Elusis,
the allseeing eyes, humanistic
psychology. This is one of the Robert
Miller school's teaching points. Here's
Franco, a shamanic facilitator,
astrology, sacred circle operator,
author of initiation and astro
shamanism. He talks to inner guides.
What else? He says the workshop offers
practical stools for journeying into
ecstatic dimensions
beyond conventional time. He says the
program includes shamanic journeys,
drumming, ceremonial sharing, soul
retrieving, connection with guides and
spirits. This is spiritism of the worst
kind. This is forbidden in the Bible. No
wonder the Bible is not part of this
organization's book. Robert Miller says,
"At the world level, the UN has adopted
a world economic development strategy,
food, agriculture, world, there's a
world food plan, a world health plan, a
world literacy plan, a world employment
plan, a world industry plan. They've got
every single detail of our lives sewn
up." Now, another organization that's
very important is UNESCO.
And let's just look at UNESCO. It's a
suborganization of the United Nations.
Julian Huxley is the former director of
UNESCO. He was humanist of the year.
He's a theistic philosopher, member of
the communistic colonial bureau of
British Fabian Society and signer of the
humanist manifesto too. That's not a
very good recommendation as far as I'm
concerned. Some more skull and bones
member Archable Mleas wrote the UNESCO
constitution. So he must be an
Illuminati member as we saw in that
lecture on the secret behind secret
societies. So Freemasons helped create
the organization a fervent international
mleasleash. He is associated with one
worldism. Here's another one. Neibbor is
UNESCO's co-founder and he signed COS
Now what does that mean? Which appeared
in 1969
and uh they printed it in the New York
Times. Then what is COS? This is these
are the founders. It is the position of
CKOS that contraceptive services should
be available to all including minors who
should enjoy the same rights of free and
independent access to contraceptive care
as to others. It is the position of CKOS
that the use of explicit sexual mater
materials, sometimes referred to as
pornography, can serve a variety of
important needs in the lives of
countless individuals. These are nice
people up there in the United Nations.
No wonder now it is forced curriculum at
even junior schools to have explicit
sexual details explained all in the
names of preventing sexual diseases.
with the most strange and lurid acts
which have to be performed. In fact, our
universities are granting honorary
doctorates to those who are the most
perverse on the stage. Yes,
Huxley who was the initial chairman in
its educational program can stress the
ultimate need for world political unity,
familiarize all people with the
implications of transfer of full
sovereignty and etc etc. So these people
are all birds of a feather.
UNESCO explains, "If UNESCO is attacked
on the grounds that it is helping to
prepare the world's people for world
government, then it is an error to burst
forth with apologetic statements and
denials. Let us face it, the job of
UNESCO is to help create and promote the
elements of world citizenship. When
faced with such a charge, let us by all
means affirm it from the housetops."
That's what UNESCO says itself. So
they're not denying anything. Under
Huxley's guidance, they prepared a guide
book for teachers. Now, I would like the
parents to take a note. Everybody with
little children or have children with
little children, take note. What is the
United Nations guide book for teachers?
It says reminds them that the
destruction of a child's love of country
and patriotism is the first step in
educating that child for world
citizenship. Now, let's have a look at
what the guide book contains. Volume
five, page on the opening page. In the
classroom with children under 13 years
of age, before the child enters school,
his mind has already been profoundly
marked, often injurously, by earlier
influences, first gained, however dimly
in the home. Oh,
that's interesting. So, this must be
changed. Who is putting these thoughts
into the minds of children? them the
parents that must be changed. So
UNESCO's aim is to change the mindset of
your children to turn it against any
values that the parents might instill in
the mind of that child. Isn't that
breaking the fifth commandment? Yes or
no? Honor your father and your mother
that you may have a long life. Isn't
this breaking the fifth commandment? I
think it is. On page eight, the teacher
is told, "The kindergarten or infant
school has a significant part to play in
the child's education. Not only can it
correct many of the errors of home
training, but can also prepare the child
for membership at about age seven in a
group of his own ancient habits. The
first of many such social
identifications that he must achieve on
his way to membership in a world
society." Aha, the kindergarten. So now
the governments of the world are saying
you must send your kids to school
earlier.
Did you know that that the governments
are beginning to say that? And England
now passed a rule when this year. This
very year. Guess when kids go to school
from this year onwards in England?
Age three.
Yes. Age three. You have to send them to
preschool. That's nice and the mothers
love it because they don't have to take
care of the kids. But who's controlling
the mindset of the kids? And who's
behind it? Occultists.
Page 58 of the guide book to teacher
says, as we have pointed out, it is
frequently the family that infects the
child with extreme nationalism. The
school should therefore use the means
described earlier to combat family
attitudes. Now, nationalism is not their
ultimate game. What is their real game?
Religion.
Religion. Volume five, page 11. In our
view, history and geography should be
taught at this age at a universal
history and geography. The study of
history raises problems of value which
are better postponed until the pupil is
freed from nationalist prejudice which
is present surrounds the teaching of
history. So the whole mindset of the
child must be changed in the teaching
program. And this is UNESCO's aim. Not a
very
well noble aim I don't think because the
authority of religion and parents
especially Christian religion will be
undermined.
Now another organization comes in that
is called the Finnhorn organization and
they promote ecological health and
prosperity. Have you heard much about
ecology in the world today? Yes. Now
again we have to find the links. You
always have to do some detective work
because Francis, this is Francis of
Aissi, connected with nature, Pope John
Paul 2 named him the patron saint of
ecology. Now St. Francis was the
roommate of Ignatius Lyola, the Jesuit
founder. Just went for a sake. It is on
St. Frances day that thousands of people
flocked to St. John the Divine. Oh, how
boring. Cathedral for the blessing of
the beasts.
Also, occultist Robert Miller, that's
now the secret under secretary general
of the United Nations, former one,
informs us that Francis has been
declared patron saint of the United
Nations. The pope does it. United
Nations follows. Who's really in
control?
The Pope. And there he is. If you want
to, you can pray to him. If you don't
want to, you can ignore it.
The UN Secretary General Euant formed
the organization Planetary Citizens with
new age activist Donald Keys. Now we're
getting the links. There's the top man,
the United Nations with Donald Keys.
Planetary Citizen is now a global
government organization within the UN
specifically devoted to preparing people
for the coming of a new culture. Now
let's go on with Donald Keys. He's
together with Uton. Donald Keys has been
actively involved in Finnhorn. Have you
got the link? United Nations Secretary
General Utant Donald Keys Finh Horn in
Scotland and writes regularly for its
magazine one earth. Keys wrote the new
age groups are focusing on entering a
new stage, a world rellated stage. They
are becoming mature enough to begin to
shoulder some of the load of humanity's
burdens. The spread of new age values as
unifying yeast in the human loaf may be
the critical ingredient for successful
emergence from the 1980s onwards. Now
let's see what Finnhorn is all about.
Here we go. Their logo is the flame of
Lucifer. They use uh occult symbols.
They use the lotus flower. They talk
about divinely ordinary, divinely human.
So what are they saying? We're God and
God spoke to me. Now, who's that God
that speaks to them? Well, let's ask
their spokesman. This is David Spangler.
There's one of his books, Parents as
Parent as mystic, Mystic as parent. So,
this is what your education is going to
do to your kids. Do you know that?
David Spangler, co-director,
spokesperson for Fenorn Community in
Northern Scotland. That's what he looks
like today. Let's see what he says. He
writes in the reflections of Christ,
"The true light of Lucifer cannot be
seen through sorrow, through darkness,
through the rejection. The true light of
this great being can only be recognized
when one's own eyes can see with the
light of the Christ, the light of the
inner son. Lucifer works within each one
of us to bring us to wholeness."
Uh, and as we move into the new age,
which is the age of man's wholeness.
They love that word wholeness.
Each of us in some way is brought to the
point which is termed lucif which I term
luciferic initiation. The particular
doorway through which the individual
must pass if he is to come fully into
the presence of his light and wholeness.
Lucifer comes to give us the final gift
of wholeness. So who are these people
actually worshiping?
Lucifer directly. Lucifer prepares man
in all ways for the experience of
Christthood. Oh, we become Christ and
Christ prepares man for the experience
of God. But the light that reveals to us
the presence of the Christ, the light
that reveals to us the path of Christ
comes from Lucifer. He is the
lightgiver. He's aptly named the morning
star because it is his light that
heralds for man the dawn of a greater
consciousness. David Spangler. There he
says it straight out. David Spangler
writes, "We can take all the scriptures
and all the teachings and all the
tablets and all the laws and all the
marshmallows and have a jolly good
bonfire and marshmallow roast because
that is all they are worth."
Okay? I don't think they like the Bible
very much or the law of God. These are
the movers and shakers of the United
Nations. They're waiting for a new
economic order. Well, I'm not going to
go into those details. We affirm that
the economy of all nations is a seamless
web. They want to join it together and
uh a new international
economic order. That's world goodwill
commentary all there by itself. We the
members of the United Nations solemnly
proclaim our united determination to
work urgently for the establishment of a
new economic international order. The
whole world is going to be controlled at
every single level by these people. A
complete change in the world's financial
and economic order is imperative.
Benjamin Cream, spokesman for Matraa.
So, UN General Assembly says new
international economic order. And so, we
have all these strange happenings.
Bachmister Fuller says don't give me any
other job. Just let me be head of the
World Food Authority and I'll have the
whole world at my feet tomorrow. They're
going to use food to create enough
tension to make everyone accept this.
Benjamin Cream also wrote, "The
industrialists, economists,
administrators of great experience and
achievement who with a hierarchy, that's
a bunch of demons by the way, have
worked out plans and blueprints which
will solve the redistribution problems
of the world when the political will is
there to implement them." So that means
when they start stealing from those who
have and give it to all the others.
Matraa himself this
new age Christ the UN is the major hope
of the world in its inter relationships
we can see democracy writ large the
symbol for the expression of God's will
that men call goodwill with the advent
of the Christ this good will will bring
all men and all nations into correct
relationships and create the necessary
circumstances for the expression of that
synthesis which will be the outstanding
keynote of the coming civilization in
this vast enterprise The UN will play a
major role. Remember Revelation 17, the
10 horns you saw are 10 kings who have
not yet received a kingdom but for one
hour will receive authority as kings
along with the beast. They have one
purpose to give their power and
authority to the beast and they will
make war against the lamb. 10 regions
according to Gary H. Carr the club of
Rome divided the world into and wrote
the new constitution.
And we have this new civilization
and it was held at the Fairmont Hotel
Masonic Auditorium in San Francisco.
Conference document says we are
experienced the birth of a first global
civilization, a historic timely global
initiative 1995.
And there it was and they were ready for
it. CIA, NATO, MI5, CRI,
all of these have occult symbols in them
which we don't have to go into details.
The trilateral commission, the 666, the
666 is in the Federal Reserve. SSS, that
was the original sixth letter of the
Greek alphabet. F is the sixth letter of
our alphabet. This all spells 666.
Now, what about these world religions?
Now, this is the crux of the matter. And
if we can concentrate on this issue
tonight, this will be
the hub of what is going to happen. Was
it not inevitable that the UN would
sooner or later also acquire a spiritual
dimension? That's what Robert Miller
says. The big man behind world
education, world media,
University of Peace, all of these
things. Robert Meler writes, "There's a
famous poster which shows Christ
knocking at the tall United Nations
building wanting to enter it. I often
visualize in my mind another even more
accurate painting that of a United
Nations which would be the body of
Christ."
Interesting. Doesn't Christ say my
kingdom is not of this world? So this is
another kingdom and this Christ is
definitely not Jesus Christ. He then
refers to Pope John Paul said that we
are stone cutters and artisans of a
cathedral which we might never see in
its finished beauty.
Ah this is Masonic language that Pope
John Paul 2 is talking about.
The tapestry of its work encompasses the
total condition of humankind on this
planet. All this is part of one of the
most predigious pages of evolution. It
will require the detachment and
objectivity of future historians to
appraise fully what happened in the last
third of our century and to understand
the real significance of what the United
Nations was.
No human force will ever be able to
destroy the United Nations.
Interesting. For the United Nations is
not a mere building or a mere idea. It
is not a manmade
creation. This is Robert Miller
speaking. Under sec, former under
secretary general of the United Nation.
It wasn't man-made, then who made it?
Who made it? If man didn't make it?
Well, they told us who the leader is in
so many words. Who is he?
>> Lucifer.
Okay. The United Nations is the vision
light of the absolute supreme masonic
signal language, which is slowly,
steadily, and unearnly illuminating. You
know the buzzwords by now. The
ignorance, the night of our human life.
The divine success and supreme progress
of the United Nations is bound to become
a reality. At his choice hour, the
absolute supreme will ring his own
victory bell here on earth through the
loving and serving heart of the United
Nations.
>> Wow. This is a bomber. He's going to
ring his victory bell. Thank you, Robert
Miller. What else do you have to say? on
the issue.
Decide to open yourself to the potential
of the human race, to the infinity of
your inner self, and you will become the
universe at long last, your real divine
self. That really puts it all in the
picture. I'm more and more drawn to some
of the very simple but extremely
important teachings of the Christ. And
of all the great prophets and
visionaries, I'm increasingly convinced
that what they foresaw is the beginning
to become a reality on the planet and
that humanity is transcending or
metamorphosing itself into what those
great dreamers and visionaries and
prophets envisioned. We're changing.
We're going to undergo a change. The
world's major religions in the end all
want the same thing, do they? Even
though they were born in different
places, different circumstances, what
the world needs today is a convergence
of the different religions in the search
and definition of the cosmic and divine
laws which ought to regulate the
behavior on this planet. Worldwide,
spiritual ecommenism expressed in new
forms of religious cooperation
institutions would probably be closest
to the hearts of the resurrected Christ.
Thank you. Very interesting.
Peace will be impossible,
Robert Müller speaking, without the
taming of fundamentalism
through a united religions that
professes faithfulness only to the
global spirituality and the health of
the planet.
So fundamentalism has to be tamed. Let's
start with Islam. Where do you think
they will end?
Certainly with Christianity,
the new world religion must be based on
those truths which have stood the test
of the ages. They are steadily taking
shape in human thinking and for them the
United Nations fights.
My great personal dream, writes Robert
Miller, is to get a tremendous alliance
between all the major religions and the
United Nations. This is fascinating
stuff.
There will be not be any dissociation
between the universal church and the
sacred lodge of all true masons and the
inner circle of the esoteric society.
That said Alice a Bailey. Robert Miller
says that's their philosophy. So there
you have it. Freemasonry luciferianism.
This is the kingdom on earth.
June 1995, an interfaith summonth
conference was held in San Francisco for
the purpose of uniting the world's
religions into a global organizations,
the United Religions Organizations
called UR.
It will be an international
interreligious organization
modeled after and affiliated with the
United Nations. According to its
literature, it says Howard Dispatch
Ministry. The URO launched its written
charter in June 1997. The institution
should be fully in place by June 2000,
globally operational by June 2005.
How far is that off?
Oh, that's just around the corner. I get
excited.
Cooperating closely with the UN and its
organizations to complement the UN's
political, diplomatic, etc. The
interfaith conference, Anglican Bishop
William E. Swing issued the challenge
for a new global civilization. He said,
"We stand on the threshold of a new
world order that may be defined either
by an increasing polarization that fuels
a spiral of escalating conflict and
violence
or by growing global cooperation that
calls the human race to work across
national, ethnic, and religious
boundaries to serve a low larger global
good." see where we're heading.
Robert Miller and this is very exciting.
Dispatch magazine. Do not worry if not
all religions will join the United
Religions Organization.
Many nations did not join the UN at the
beginning but later regretted it and
made every effort to join. It was the
same with the European community. It
will be the case with the world's
religions because whoever stays out or
aloof will sooner or later regret it.
Wow. Now that's fascinating. Where we
going? Sooner or later regret it. This
man over here is Joseph Reid. He's the
under secretary general of the United
Nations currently. And here he's
speaking at the a huge convention of
Seventh Day Adventists
and he's going to tell them exactly who
is going to be in control. Let's listen
to him.
>> I make this appeal because the United
Nations is also your organization,
our world organization,
your United Nations.
Delegates,
please remember
the United Nations is the only machinery
we have for collective cooperation among
all nations.
It is the only worldwide institution for
furthering development.
The United Nations is the only universal
mechanism for protecting human rights.
The United Nations is the only shared
framework for strengthening
international law.
Delegates,
the United Nations is not one of the
luxuries of international life.
The work of the United Nations is of
vital importance for the betterment of
life on our planet.
>> That's very fascinating.
The United Nations is also
your organization.
It is the only body for this that that
and the other. Now that's not the speech
he wrote. He read it for Kofanan,
the secretary general of the United
Nations.
Now, I have a problem. I don't want to
be part of a Luciferian organization. I
certainly don't want to be. That's just
me personally. The mystical tradition in
the mainline denominations easily
interact with those of the heathen
religions of the world. Meditation
practices, visualization techniques,
breathing exercises are now being used
to tap into spiritual realm. And this
such religious leaders as Pope, the Pope
and the Dalai Lama are very much on the
same plane. Discernment newsletter 1996.
A religion to fit everyone.
Goals of this one world religion, world
goodwill. Remember this is all UN
affiliated organizations
founded by the very highest level of
people. The churches in and the world
religions should indicate the unity
within all facets of truth which will
provide a universal platform one to
which all men everywhere could give
allegiance. Such a platform should
include the truth that all men are
divine.
Thank you. Can we do that?
Yes or no?
I hope not. The truth that evolution
governs the growth of the human being.
I don't believe in that either.
Each individual is a god. All men are
divine. And the belief in evolution, the
fact of immortality and of eternal
persistence, reincarnation arising from
man's essential divinity. The Bible
clearly teaches us that there is no such
thing as reincarnation, for it is
appointed unto men once to die.
These are all taken from direct quotes.
Preparation for by men and women of good
will is needed to introduce new values,
new standards, new attitudes, prepare
for a coming world teacher, requirements
of a new world order and a
reorganization of social structure. I
want nothing to do with that. I want
nothing to do with that. Alice Bailey
writes, "The same old formulas, the same
old theologies, the same old
interpretations are deemed adequate to
meet men's modern needs and inquiries.
They are not. The church today is the
tomb of the Christ and the stone of
theology has been rolled to the door of
the sele." Oh,
Jesus and his theology. Goodbye.
Goodbye.
She writes, "The day is dawning when all
the religions will be regarded as
emanating from one great spiritual
source. All will be seen as unitedly
providing one root out of which the
universal world religion will inevitably
emerge.
Then there will be neither Christian nor
heathen, neither Jew nor Gentile, but
simply one great body of believers
gathered out of all the current
religions." That sounds nice.
But whose religion will it be?
They will accept the same truths not as
theological concepts but as essential to
spiritual living. They will stand
together on the same platform of
brotherhood and of human relations. They
will recognize divine sunship will seek
unitedly to cooperate with the divine
plans. Such a world religion is no idol
dream but something which is definitely
forming today.
World goodwill letter 1993 quoting it.
These are United Nations organizations.
So obviously the world is going to move
towards this unified platform and there
will be some who propagate a spirit of
separateness. Is that correct? Can we
see that emerging? And then there will
be conflict.
And Robert Miller says that those who do
not want to go along with this will
sooner or later come to regret it. So
obviously we're heading for a clash.
Thus the expressed aims and efforts of
the United Nations will be eventually
brought to function and a new church of
God gathered out of all the religions
and spiritual groups. Wow. A new church
of God. I don't want to be part of that
new church of God. I find it
nauseiating.
Miller also said, "We must hope also
that the Pope will come before the year
2000 to the United Nations, speak for
all the religions and spiritualities on
this planet and give the world the
religious view of how the third
millennium should be a spiritual
millennium. A millennium which will see
the integration and harmony of humanity.
Who must be the spokesman for this new
world religion?"
The Pope. The plan is coming together.
Revelation is unfolding. This is exactly
what the Bible speaks about what will
happen. Instead of becoming dejected and
miserable,
then lift up your heads and start
smiling because we're going home. This
is exciting.
The world's major religions must speed
up dramatically their ecumenical
movement and recognize the unity of
their objectives and diversity of of
their cults. Religions must actively
cooperate to bring to unprecedented
heights a better understanding of the
mysteries of life and of our place in
the universe. My religion, right or
wrong, and my nation, right or wrong,
must be abandoned forever in the
planetary age. You're not allowed to say
Jesus is the only way. It must be
abandoned forever.
I'm sorry. I will not abandon it. I
refuse.
And then we had this wonderful meeting.
The Pope actually did appear before the
United Nations. And then they came
together in this massive rehearsal at
the United Nations where they formed
this new ecumenical initiative funded by
Ted Turner and the whole world is
gathering into one new religious pot
under the United Nations. And I saw one
of the heads, as it were, wounded to
death, and his deadly wound was healed,
and all the world wondered after the
beast. Revelation 13
3 Joshua 24:15.
And if it seems evil unto you to serve
the Lord, choose you this day whom you
will serve, whether the gods which your
forefathers serves that were on the
other side of the flood, or the gods of
the Amorites in whose land you dwell.
But as for me and my house, we will
serve the Lord. That's the decisions we
have to make. Those are the issues
before us. And the sad thing is, I'm not
making this up. I'm just reading it off
the screen. I'm really not making this
up. I wish I was, but I'm not.
So, we are actually facing a crisis
situation.
But in the lectures that are now coming,
we will have to look at the other side
of the coin. We've had enough of this
side of the coin. Don't you think? I'm
sick to death of it already. Now let's
have a look whether God has an answer to
what Satan is planning.
Now I handed out or I had handed out
another little card over here and I've
got a question on there.
I'm beginning to see that the battle is
not really political.
Did you see that tonight? Battle is not
really political but religopolitical.
They want your allegiance and your mind.
I see that the devil has it so set up
that the whole world and even if
possible the very elect are to be
deceived and mesmerized
by his devices.
By God's grace, the second point, I do
not want to be one of those that are
deceived. I see that it is more than
just being aware of the problem. I see
that I will have to make a concerted
effort to find truth and to become and
remain undeceived. What is the only
channel whereby we can find out the will
of God? You tell me.
The Bible. If God hadn't given us the
Bible, we would be hopelessly at sea.
Thank God God gave us the Bible. What
would we do without it? I wouldn't know
where we're going. It would all seem
logical. It would all seem okay.
Everybody would be happy to climb onto
this bandwagon. Right or wrong?
I want to know how Jesus will be victor
in this controversy.
All we've seen is Satan build up his
kingdom. And that's exactly what the
book of Revelation is about. I'm
interested in learning more and to plan
to attend the next lectures because this
is where the counter plan of God will
start to be discussed. We're now going
to go back to the Bible and we're going
to find out what God has in store for
us. But if I could just be so daring as
to ask,
just show me your hands if you want to.
Who sees that Jesus is being eradicated
from the world plan? who sees it?
Wow. So, there's a total onslaught on
Jesus Christ and we are just caught in
the battle. Isn't that right? We're just
caught in the battle. So, what hope have
we got of changing the status quo?
None.
None. If you think you can change this,
forget it. We have no hope. Who is our
only hope?
Jesus Christ. He is our only hope.
Without him, we are nothing. And that's
why I can stand here today because I
know there's nothing I can do. But he
can do something. He's even made it
possible for me to stand here and speak
to you. Isn't that great?
All things are possible. Do you know
that I've given these lectures in a
Masonic Hall?
Yes. All things are possible.
Absolutely amazing.
Heat. Heat.
I don't know.